en plein coeur de manhattan ce somptueux
édifice centenaire entre dans une
nouvelle ère vous avec super rire vous
faites ça ainsi avec l'interrupteur et
là ça prend une autre dimension
[Musique]
oui tout à fait multiples dimensions
ani le building au complet et puis on a
créé une vidéo mapping sur 360 degrés
pour vraiment mettre en guinée murs mais
aussi de démontrer la beauté
architecturale de l'environnement sous
pour rio c'est la plus récente
réalisation de la compagnie moment
factory
on a dix-sept projecteurs haute
définition ont installé de façon bien
été gris parce qu'on voulait respecter
l'architecturé donc on ne pouvait pas
toucher les murs de la projection des
jeux de lumières et des prouesses de
haute technologie voilà ce qui a fait la
renommée internationale de l'entreprise
québécoise la cathédrale de reims qui
prend vie un décor virtuel en plein
aéroport de singapour
de grands lancements de nouveaux
produits partout dans le monde ou encore
des spectacles époustouflants
moment factory est parti à chaque fois
qu'on produit et tout part d'ici à
montréal c'est ce moment particulier se
voir cette émotion qui est différente et
nouvelle
on est tellement habitué de regarder sur
l'écran on est tellement habitué que
juste part des trucs des technologies
ont créé des effets trompe l'oeil des 3d
font que les gens sont un peu surpris
médusés par le résultat c'est dans ses
bureaux que 400 personnes essayent de
méduses et la planète
chaque projet réalisé devient leur carte
de visite pour obtenir le contrat
suivant
évidemment madonna les a appelés pour
son spectacle de la mi-temps du
superbowl madonna prémunir j'ai beaucoup
dé vue de caméra très large alors toute
la partie sur le sol qu'on a fait est
devenu un des éléments de signature de
moment factory
de quoi attirer aussi les nouvelles
sensations moment moman factory a
réalisé pour la prestation en direct de
bill english ce tour de force qui semble
défier la gravité
[Musique]
un produit clé en main dont moment
factory connaît le secret ces trucs du
métier on veut pas donner la magie on
veut pas révéler le secret alors l'idée
c'est vraiment surprendre toujours et
c'est donc maintenant au tour de new
york et d'être surpris avec son père il
ya une série de cinq raël 45 minutes en
cinq tableaux où s'expriment des rêves
d'une autre époque et d'une autre
dimension
surpris éric fournier l'a été quand
barcelone l'a appelé pour son église de
la nativité
quand l'appel est venu je me demandais
s'il n'y avait pas un truc comme jouet
une surprise avec une caméra cachée
quelque part parce qu'en terme de
mapping sur la façade de la nativité le
travail de gaudi une église aussi
iconique
c'était vraiment un défi un peu spécial
malgré tout même simone factory un
succès planétaire
l'entreprise veut rester à une échelle
humaine si on parle du 30 projets qui
nous sont amenés à chaque semaine on va
en rester à peu près trois ou quatre
alors c'est plus la majorité qu'on est
donc j'ai dire ou non n'a pas le temps
en attendant l'entreprise continue de
multiplier les projets ponctuels comme
la série d'élus mine à un spectacle
interactif dans la forêt
maintenant bien installé à londres paris
los angeles tokyo et new york
l'entreprise risque plus que jamais de
charmer les foules en tant que faiseur
de rêves les surprendre décrit vraiment
des moments uniques à travers ce qu'on
fait bien avec avec la technologie de
leur faire oublier qu'il ya de la
technologie leur prochain projet reculer
encore d'autres limites tant que la
technologie le permettra
[Musique]